in this video i'm going to share the
most common way
to get out of an awkward conversation
which is also perhaps the most terrible
way to get out of an awkward
conversation
i'm also going to share three strategies
that are way better
that you can use and apply in your own
context and situation
to get out of an awkward situation my
name is chad i'm the co-author of this
lovely book i'll ask powerful questions
create conversations that matter and at
the end of this video
these three strategies will help you
shift all of your awkward
painful heart raising conversations
into conversations that really matter
let's get into it
[Music]
the most terrible way and unfortunately
the most common way to get out of an
awkward conversation
is to lie and make an excuse that isn't
really based in reality
so that you can just excuse yourself
and this doesn't feel good for anybody
because even somebody with a pretty low
level of social or emotional
intelligence
knows when you tell them your dog ate
your homework it feels
much better when there's some
transparency that happens
now the the reason that you might want
to get out of an awkward conversation is
because it's awkward
and so to be transparent and say hey
this is really awkward
i'm going to leave now is also very
awkward right so you want to avoid that
and so in this video we're going to
unpack three strategies that are way
better alternatives
to get out of an awkward conversation
instead of lying making up an excuse
because that never feels too good you
can do that right there's nothing
stopping you from doing that
but it won't feel great for you and it
definitely won't feel great for the
person who you're ditching
all three of these strategies that i'm
gonna share became way more clear to me
after i did something that was
remarkably uncomfortable
and awkward for me because a big part of
my job working with some of the top
leaders and educators on the planet is
to invite them to stretch outside of
their comfort zone
i think i also need to be practicing
that myself as well and so every year
i pick something pretty big and
uncomfortable to dive into
and a few years ago i signed up for a
10-day
silent meditation retreat 10 days no
reading no phone no journaling no tv no
speaking to anybody else
no eye contact even with the people that
they were there
meals were taken in silence at tables
this was like
very outside of my comfort zone and i
learned
a really phenomenal lesson in that that
helped me
navigate awkward conversations and it
was this concept of a nietzsche
i think it's a hindi word and it
basically means uh
rising passing rising passing it's the
idea that everything is
impermanent right and so at some point
if your back hurts
at some point it'll hurt and at some
point it won't and
at some point you'll feel really awkward
and uncomfortable in a conversation
and at some point you won't making that
come alive the first strategy to get out
of an awkward conversation
is to relabel it who labeled the
conversation
awkward it was you the other person
might be feeling awkward in that
conversation but not necessarily
and so for you to label that
conversation as awkward
makes it a thing right as soon as you
put a label to it like that
it now becomes that much more real
and so the first strategy is simply to
relabel the conversation
and say this is not an awkward
conversation this is a conversation in
progress
and when you make that shift all of a
sudden that conversation is changeable
and you don't need to live in that
awkwardness
second strategy oh that's gonna be
really loud probably not gonna do that
okay second strategy shift the focus
from this person to
this person shift the focus from you to
them when you're labeling a conversation
awkward that is a label that describes
how
you are currently feeling because you
can't actually
know how they're feeling now you might
be able to pick up
there are signs that people are feeling
awkward in a conversation
but the only way that you can really
know if something's awkward is if you're
experiencing it
and so i found one of the most powerful
ways to shift that dynamic
is to take the focus off of yourself and
turn it onto the other person
focus on what they're experiencing what
would make this conversation
more interesting more useful more
valuable for them
as opposed to focusing on yourself of
how you can get back to a place
of comfort and i don't say that lightly
right like part of my
job before i started we and me was
studying social anxiety and so i know
that being awkward in a conversation can
be serious it's not just like
oh this is an awkward conversation i
want to get out of it i recognize that
some conversations are
deeply uncomfortable and so these
strategies are not like
flip a switch and then you just make
them happen right they take some
some time and attention and practice
it's like a muscle
right and so if if you're if you've been
labeling conversations as awkward for a
long time
you need to re-label them as in progress
for a while
before you're going to start to feel
like you can really shift the focus in
conversation and practice this second
strip
practice the second strategy of shifting
the focus away from you and on to
them the third strategy comes from the
foundational
and first chapter of our book which is
and the entire book is structured
in this pyramid framework the first
tool concept that we share in the book
is intention and the third strategy to
get out of awkward conversations
is to put a purpose on those
conversations put an intention to those
conversations in particular
in particular i would invite you to get
clear on what is your intention
in that conversation and share it with
the other person
a lot of times conversations feel
awkward because
two people don't know why they're in
them so if you think about
like small talk obligatory small talk
you bump into somebody an event
or you show up both on uh five minutes
early for a video call
and you're kind of just there right that
might be a place where a conversation
feels awkward
to you and i would argue it's awkward
because there's no intention or purpose
established
and so your intention can be as simple
as i'm really
curious to actually that can be the
intention is curiosity
but stating that to the person let's
just say for example
that you bumped into somebody at an
event you have never met them before
you're in a conversation you've asked uh
where are you from what do you do
a couple other questions that are just
like in your back pocket they've just
plugged a dvd
or a usb drive into their head and like
spit out what they said the last 15
times they answered that question
and so that is creating some level of
awkwardness
what i would invite you to do with this
person in the moment is get really clear
about your intention and state it to say
hey i know it's uh typically when we're
in
this feels very intimate this feels
strangely intimate
if i'm in a conversation with this
person
what i'm what my intention might be and
your intention might be different but
personally
if i've just bumped into somebody brand
new i might say
typically when we bump into somebody at
an event like this
we ask like the same four questions and
you give the same four answers
and so i know there's a little bit odd
but i'm actually curious
to not ask those questions and i'm
curious what a highlight from
the last week was for you there is
social risk
in doing something there's social risk
in asking a question that's outside of
the norm
and yet that conversation can go from
painful awkward obligatory small talk to
a more meaningful conversation if you
take that risk
and actually state your intention to
that person this video was
fun to shoot i hope it was fun to watch
if you want to get out of all awkward
conversations in the future
there's a link below with a free excerpt
from
our book ask powerful questions create
conversations that matter
in that excerpt there's a whole bunch of
tools that will help you have
much more intentional meaningful
conversations
also the two videos linked here will
help you dive a little bit deeper as
well
have an awesome day
you